- [Mike] You are in the SAS
412, we are going to talk about
cost-efficient, multi-tenant
knowledge bases.
If this isn't the talk you want to be,
you're not gonna hurt our feelings.
You're welcome to go and find one
that's a better fit for you.
But my name is Mike Gillespie.
I've been with AWS a
little over nine years,
and I really like these
types of engagements
where we're talking with our customers,
learning about what
problems they're facing.
So as a co-talk,
this is going to be very
interactive, like this,
these are very dull if you
guys don't participate.
So we're leaning on you, depending on you.
I will, when the time comes,
I will go round and bring a mic
so everyone can hear your questions.
There'll be times when you stump us.
That's fine.
You know, we don't know everything, but-
- [Steven] Never!
That would never happen.
- That would never happen?
Eh, it's happened to me.
- It happens.
- [Mike] It won't happen to you.
That's what happened.
Steven, do you wanna introduce yourself?
- [Steven] Hi, I'm Steven Warwick,
solutions architect at AWS,
for the last 5 1/2 years.
But definitely a builder,
I was an engineer before
for, god, 30 years or so,
building various things and all
across different industries.
So enjoy very much the
SaaS-based architectures though,
and been working with customers on that
ever since I started with AWS.
So that's what we're
gonna dive into today.
- [Mike] Yeah, and we both
work with software companies,
so we're familiar with the challenges
that software companies face every day.
And the origin of this came from something
Steven was working on.
People came to him, asked him about
how to build knowledge bases.
He's like, "Well, happy to help you."
And then it came into, well,
we need to have, you know,
different tenants and different-
- [Steven] We need to section things out.
Imagine that!
We, like not how-
- Yeah, section them out.
- [Steven] people look at the same stuff
and get the same answers.
- [Mike] So we'll start
off by talking about
what are knowledge bases.
I'm sure with AI,
many of you are already
familiar with that,
but we wanna set a baseline
of what we're talking about today.
And then some of the
challenges that you face
running RAG type architectures
with multi-tenancy.
And we'll focus on a few of those.
We have a demo, which will
then go right into the code
and we'll show you, you know,
where in the code that these
decisions are being made,
where the logic's happening.
And that's where you come in.
That's where you can ask questions,
see how we think through these things.
And like I said at the beginning,
I love these co-talks and chalk
talks, because it gives you,
as a customer,
a window into how AWS
thinks about these problems.
You know, we see these every day,
working with our customers on AWS,
and we have a certain point of view,
and this will help you
see that and, you know,
be able to translate that
into something that you see every day.
So, go ahead.
- I was gonna say,
there's not always one
right answer either.
Our answer is definitely one
of the ways you can do it,
but-
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Steven] I think we've
had lots of comments from
even the sample coders
out in the world too.
So that's one thing we want to get to
is feedback from today.
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Steven] What do you
see out in the world
and how are you using things?
- [Mike] Yeah, and that's part of what
our point of view is.
You know, this is how we see things,
but you may approach things differently
because you have different
problems to solve.
So jumping right into it, you know,
what are some of the main design decisions
that you have to face when you're building
multi-tenant knowledge bases?
One is data segmentation.
You have tenant specific search.
You'll have one tenant
that wanna upload documents
or other resources into your application,
and then be able to have
a chat against those
or be able to search against
those in a semantic way.
But of course, the one thing you can't do,
you have one job and that is
to not let the data spill over
from one tenant to another.
So what are the mechanisms that
you can use to enforce that?
You also have a hybrid search.
So it's not just semantics search,
but also a keyword search.
And then enabling that with AI.
So how do you hook that up to a chat bot
or be able to run AI type
queries against that,
within the scope of that tenant.
- [Steven] There's a little other paradigm
that we're gonna talk about today too,
is how do you do that easily across
different types of vector
stores and things like that.
We wanna make sure that,
hey, Customer A might
want super low latency.
Customer B not so much,
they just wanna pay less
and they want to have bulk stuff.
But how do we do that in just
an easy way across the board,
so that we don't have to do
a lot of work to set that up.
- [Mike] That way you don't have to write
a whole new application for
each way you access your data.
So I've talked about this
already a little bit,
but data isolation, you know,
that is like the core tenet
of multi-tenant application,
is how do you enforce data isolation?
And, you know, the philosophy I have is
don't leave that to chance.
You have to build the
infrastructure around it
to enforce that that happens.
It was Steven called
out tiered performance.
Not all of your customers are the same.
You may have a free tier
where you're just trying to get customers
a sense for what your application can do,
but you wanna minimize
the cost or really use a
pay for what you use model,
versus established customers
that really value the latency.
You know, working with software companies
that build chat bots,
the number one complaint
customers get is latency.
I type in my question
and I have to wait 30
seconds for an answer.
That's not acceptable.
So how do you make your
application be able to balance
both the cost-effectiveness,
but also meet the latency
requirements of your customers?
And because the vector stores
that power the knowledge bases
are some of your pricier data stores,
how do you make sure that you have
the right data lifecycle management?
And there's a couple of reasons for this.
One is certainly for cost,
but also unstructured data
tends to age very quickly.
You may have an updated document
that now reflects a new version
of the state of reality.
How do you age those out
in a way that makes sense
for that particular tenant?
Did I missing anything?
- [Steven] Yeah, just
different industries,
you'll see this a lot.
So like the real estate industry,
they might want to have like segments
of their market set up,
but that real estate cycle's
changing, you know, quickly,
or patient records,
if they're throwing it
in a knowledge base.
It's like the doctor might
see someone every six months
and they might wanna throw that in
and then take it out maybe
for regulatory things as well.
They wanna make sure it's only in there
for a certain amount of time,
but also allows them to
shrink the amount of usage
that they have to use,
and only do it when they need to do it.
- [Mike] So looking at tiered performance,
the underlying vector store
that powers your database
makes a big difference.
Comparing three of these
options, and there are many more,
but looking at OpenSearch is
a very popular vector store
for the customers that I work with.
It's very low latency.
It allows you to do hybrid
search and you can have
the provision cost to meet your demand.
Compare that to pgVector,
which has the advantage of,
it's also low latency,
but it's also integrated
with your structured data.
So if you have hybrid queries
that query against structured data
and your unstructured data,
you can do that in one spot.
And then, you know, last year
at re:Invent we announced
the S3 vector bucket, which
allows you to run vector queries
against data stored in S3.
It's really cool because you
only pay for what you use,
you pay per query, and for
the data that's being stored.
You don't have that provisioned cost
that you would in OpenSearch.
However, that does come at the cost of
higher latency per query.
So, you know, the case
that I mentioned before
where you have a free tier,
you may want to have that
on the vector bucket so
that you're only paying for
that evaluation use case
that your customers are
just kicking the tires.
Whereas your more
established customers may,
you may want to have latency.
But as Steven mentioned,
we don't wanna write
three different applications more or less
to interface with our vector store.
How do we abstract that out so that we get
the simplicity of one
way to access our data,
but the flexibility to drive
the backend how we want it.
Another challenge with the
lifecycle management, you know,
how do we define rules for data retention?
How do we ensure that you're
running against the most
up to date and accurate information?
I know working at Amazon
we have an, you know,
internal wiki, which is
usually out of date, you know,
shortly after you published to it, right?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- So, how do we make sure
that the data that's in
there is actually up to date,
and age out the data appropriately?
And the tenant tiering that
we talk about is, you know,
how do you have different
rules based on the tenant?
You know, as Steven mentioned,
you may have a real estate
with a very high churn rate
of the data in your documents
in your vector store, versus
ones that may have, you know,
much longer, and be able to
configure that, per each tenant.
- [Steven] Yeah, it could be file sizes,
it could be file types,
that kind of stuff as well.
- [Mike] So given that challenge,
so the architecture that
we're demonstrating today,
and again, as Steven said,
this is not the only way
to do it, but, you know,
we found this to be a very
effective way to abstract out
what that vector store is, so
that we can simplify our code
but also give that
flexibility on the backend.
So walking through it, you
have the user interface,
it's secured with Cognito,
and that's important
because that Cognito stores which tenant
that user belongs to.
So that will be part of the JWT
token that gets sent through
so that the backend
can then make decisions
based on which tenant they belong to.
That gets sent to the Lambda function,
which uses Bedrock to do
the inference on the LLM,
and then uses the Bedrock
knowledge bases to interface with
the vector store on the backend,
whether it be in
OpenSearch, S3, et cetera.
Anything else?
- Yeah, I think that's like
one of the key things
we're gonna show is like,
how we're using the custom stores
and the custom data types and stuff,
so that you can do this in other ways
where you're storing your
files in different areas of S3
or something like that.
And you can use metadata files
and things to pull it in.
But it's an ingestion pattern
that is kind of like a fire
and do a batch pull in.
So we're gonna dive into
a little bit today of,
how you can do that in a
little bit more bespoke manner.
And we'll go through a
little bit of the code
of what that looks like
and the main key points.
We only have so much time,
so we're not gonna go through
all the code that's there,
but we wanna make sure
that you understand, hey,
these are the points you need to make,
or to build into the system to
derive like individual files
that you can pull into these
stores, for tenants, for users,
whatever way you want to
break it down as well.
- [Mike] So I'll switch over.
- [Steven] Right, and
remember, this is interactive.
If anybody's got questions
and things, feel free.
Let's see if it's coming up.
So we're gonna do a little bit of a demo,
just to kind of show you
and see what is possible.
Again, this is just kind of a tech demo
to show you what's out there.
So the first screen that
you're seeing here is Tenant A.
So I've logged in
and I've got a bunch of files
in here that I've added.
I'm trying to pre-populate
this because we all know that
the demo gods don't love us very much
and we want to make sure that it runs.
So what you'll see here is
I've got a few files in here
for Tenant A, which is an S3 vector store.
You'll notice there's a few
files that have been timed out
and then some other files
have an expiration date.
So those are the ones that
I've gone in and said,
"This file particular to me,
I want to go and add
to the knowledge base."
So it's gonna say that
you've got so much capacity.
Again, when you're building these systems,
it's probably baked in.
You won't be showing
these screens to the users
and things like that.
Of course it's gonna,
demo gods are gonna hit me in
the face for this one, but.
So imagine that gets ingested.
So now I'm Tenant A, I
am a user in the system,
I've got my indexed files in there
and then I can go and chat with that,
those particular files.
So I've already done a chat
before because, of course,
again, the demo gods.
I'm only seeing and
interacting with the files
that I have ingested.
And this could be per tenant
based or per user base.
So I've ingested these S3 files.
And I asked some questions on it.
Now I'm gonna switch
over quickly to Tenant C.
Just to kind of show you like
Tenant C's on OpenSearch.
They've got a lot more files
they're allowed to ingest,
a lot more file usage.
They can do a higher query
rate, things like that.
And you'll see that I've indexed again,
but they've got a way
longer expiration period
that they can have as well.
So while they're going through,
they can do another chat
and they're gonna be chatting
again against their own files
per tenant, per user in this case.
So when I go into a chat
in here, you'll see the,
I've got my index files
and I can go and ask it a question like,
what programming language.
This is, let's see if
we can actually get it,
if I can spell, you're using.
I can't spell at all.
- [Mike] It's like horseshoes, right?
Just-
- Yeah.
Let's see, now I think my network
is failing like crazy in here.
So we're gonna pretend
that that came back.
That's why I had the
other chat pre-populated.
So what we want to do
though is just give you
an overall view of like
what's possible, right?
So if you break it down you
can break these files down.
But we want to get into some
of what the code looks like
and how we make this happen.
So I'm gonna switch over
to our friendly neighborhood
Kiro system over here.
- [Mike] Might wanna zoom in on that.
- [Steven] Yeah, we're gonna-
- [Mike] For our friends in the back.
- [Steven] For the
people with the eyesight
that we were just talking about up here.
We're getting to that.
What prescription, I
think I need a new one.
Okay, so in here, this is my main stack,
and what I'm doing is I'm creating
a couple of the knowledge bases here.
And you'll see that I've got ones
where I might wanna set
it up or I might not.
But I wanna show you this because-
- [Mike] Just pausing one second.
When you say main stack,
what do you mean by that?
- [Steven] That's right.
This is the CDK application
that is going to build out
the infrastructure inside of AWS for us.
And this part of the
stack is the primary stack
that runs first and is building out.
I'm calling out to a bunch of other things
to build out the knowledge bases
and do the connectivity
between everything.
So I want to call this one out
because we're gonna jump into this
knowledge base class as
well in a second tier.
But you'll notice that
there's a couple of them.
There is the OpenSearch one,
and that there's a Postgres
knowledge based one.
Now I note that we said S3 vector as well.
That, the CDK constructs and
cloud formation constructs
for S3 vector are still
in the mix, I should say,
or like kind of being turned on.
So that is built off in a different stack
because I have to use the APIs
directly for those right now.
So there's custom resources
to build that out.
But for the end result
you're still going
through a knowledge base
for the querying, which we'll
get into in a second here.
So I'm going to go over-
- [Mike] So the key takeaway there is
that you're building infrastructure
to have the knowledge base,
and it's connected to
the backend vector store.
- [Steven] Yes, exactly.
So this is that knowledge base stack
that I was talking about.
And I'm gonna zoom in here.
So we've got a bunch of stuff at the top
that's setting up a few things,
just sanitizing names, things like that.
But one of the key things
we want to do first
is set up the knowledge base,
and I'm just going to
copy some things in here
to save time of me typing,
'cause nobody wants to
see me just type away.
So we've got our knowledge
base, we've got the, you know,
we're setting up the name
and things like that.
Now the next most important thing
is the knowledge base configuration.
So I'm gonna copy that in here.
And you'll see what I'm
setting up is the vector type.
You can set up these embedding
models and things like that,
whatever you want, across.
This is going to, you could
pass these in as variables again
for the particular knowledge
base that you're using.
I've set them kind of across the board
for the knowledge bases that
I'm gonna be setting up.
And then we want to do
the storage configuration.
So in this instance, this
is where I'm passing in,
I'm creating these,
this knowledge base storage configuration
and I'm passing in my
OpenSearch for my Aurora stuff.
So if we jump into there,
you'll see that for RDS I'm
setting it up a specific way.
So I'm saying, you know,
I've got my embeddings
and chunkings for RDS.
And if it's Aurora,
then we're gonna be
setting up a different way.
And then for OpenSearch we have to use,
I'm setting up with OpenSearch
serverless, and again,
I'm going into each individual one
and I'm setting up the
individual vector stores.
But once we get to the actual
query and things like that,
I don't have to worry about that.
I can just say this is
the one that I'm going to
and it's all set, each one is set up,
and I can just point it
to that and it can go.
- [Mike] So that was a lot to cover.
- [Steven] Yeah.
- [Mike] Really wanna open
up to questions or comments,
or like if, was there points,
like why did you make that
decision or what, you know,
why did we do that?
And if no one ask questions,
then I'm gonna ask questions
and I'm probably not gonna
ask the same question you are.
So any questions, raise your hand,
and I may have to step to the side to see.
- [Steven] And while he's
going to find out, there's,
the next thing that we need to set up.
We've got the knowledge
base configuration,
but we do need the data source, right?
We need to tell it where
the data is coming from.
So I am going to set up
a data source in my code,
unless there's a question-
- I have one question,
is related to the different vector stores.
What is the pros and cons for each one?
- [Steven] Sorry, I can't see.
- [Mike] Did you hear the question?
- I did not hear the question.
- The question is,
"What are the different pros and cons
for the vector stores
that you had set up?"
- [Steven] So the pros and cons,
I think Mike went over a
little bit there, right?
But it's typically what
I've seen with customers is
the price to latency ratios
that they're seeing in there.
So if it's a customer like, you know,
you might have a free tier, right,
where you really don't wanna
spend a lot of money on that.
That's just the kind of,
the way to pull the customer
in to see what you're doing.
So you might use an S3 vector store there
because the latency on every question
might be a little longer, depending.
This is bang for your buck.
You're gonna have to go in there
a little bit with yourself,
depending on the file types you're using
and things like that.
So it's kind of on YouTube,
do a little bit of research
to figure that out.
But we have seen, you know, also there's,
if you're using Postgres already,
and you're using OpenSearch,
you might just want to go those routes.
- [Mike] To add onto that,
I mean that's typically
what I've seen is like
we are familiar with Postgres,
we know how to run it,
we know how to operate it
and we need a low latency vector store.
It's a good fit for, versus
OpenSearch, you know,
we have many customers that run OpenSearch
for other purposes.
It's just a natural fit to
put their vector in Postgres.
But, you know, there's
many others, you know.
Pinecone would be an example.
So there's probably a whole
talk just on, you know,
pick your vector store.
But, you know, really the point here is,
one size does not fit all.
Like you'll likely want
to have multiple options
with different dimensions,
and the kind of the
extreme with latency being
S3 versus OpenSearch, or one other.
Does that help or?
Yeah.
I'll be right back.
Unless you can yell and
I'll repeat the question.
I'll come back.
- [Steven] You can jump back there.
- [Mike] There you go.
- [Audience Member] I was curious.
So right now we have a knowledge base
with fairly small tabular data
that's loaded in S3 and
using OpenSearch for that.
I was wondering if for small tables
it will be worth it moving
to the Postgres vector,
since it's tabular data.
And will there be any accuracy
implications for the agent
that uses that knowledge base?
- [Steven] That's gonna
be a tough question
for me to answer.
There's, if you look,
there are some samples
out in the AWS samples, GitHub repo,
that kind of on the, they let you run
your own kind of performance
testing on this kind of stuff.
What we found is it really depends on
the type of data that you
have and the size of data.
And to your point of like,
how many columns there might be in there,
different types of things
that has to chunk out.
And there's quite a
vast difference between
the embeddings that you're using,
the chunking size that you're using.
So it's really difficult,
without looking at your data
and doing some performance-testing first,
to really figure that out.
That's why we kind of usually
go back to the customer
and say like, "Let's do a
couple of demo runs of this."
And use some of the samples
that we have out there
on your data to figure that out.
- [Mike] Yeah, and I'll
stress that the embedding
and the chunking have a much bigger impact
on the quality of the search
than necessarily what the
engine running the math is.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Steven] All right, while he's jumping
to another question, I'm gonna
add in the data source here.
'Cause I think this is
one of the key things
when you're creating the data
source for the knowledge base.
We're setting the data source
configuration to be custom,
and this is one of the
key points in here is
this allows us to actually say,
instead of going to the
data, like to have an S3
and just pulling everything
in when the files are there,
we want to do this very bespoke
and we want to do it custom.
So that's, we're setting it
up to be exactly like that.
And you'll see once we
get into the ingest part,
so I'm gonna just copy
the rest of this in here
just so you see what it looks like.
So I've set up my data source
now, I've got the custom.
And we're going through
stages here, right?
Set up the data source,
set up the knowledge base.
We're gonna get into the
ingest next and the query,
and then what it looks
like when we time out data
and cleaning that up.
But, sorry, Mike,
was there another question?
- Did you still have
a question on that?
- [Audience Member] If we need
to inject the caching layer
on the previous
architecture, how it can fit?
- Sorry, I didn't quite hear.
- How would we put
a caching layer on top
of that previous layer,
on top of the vector store?
- [Steven] That's a very good question,
not one that I've thought of.
I mean you, depends on if
you're using like CloudFront
as a fronting mechanism
or something like that,
you could try to do some
caching of the results in there.
Hmm.
I'm sure you could
probably use ElastiCache
and some other tooling
in there if you wanted.
But I don't have a bespoke
answer for that from here.
And the caching wasn't
part of this system per se.
Another question.
- One more.
Then we'll move on.
- [Audience Member] What are
some advantages you've seen
to adding the knowledge
base layer, versus, uh-
- [Steven] Going directly
to the individual?
Yeah, actually, so-
- We'll cover that stuff-
- [Steven] Yeah, we're
gonna kind of go into that
and kind show why we
might want to do this.
So ingest and querying
are part of those things.
So I'm gonna go to the
ingest section here.
So this is a Python file
that's gonna be doing
my ingestion of my documents.
So this is when I clicked
a couple of those files
and I said, "Hey, run the
ingestion for just these files."
They're sitting in S3 so
my users uploaded them.
I don't want them to be in
my vector store at all times.
I just want to do it at particular times.
So you'll see in here that
I'm running through the files
and I'm gonna set up a document structure.
And this is one of the key things
that we're gonna go through here is,
we're gonna set up a content type and-
- Can you zoom?
- Oh yeah.
Hey, thanks from the audience.
So we've got a document
and we've got a content,
and again the data source type is custom
and we're giving it a file identifier
and the location of the file,
and we're saying it's S3.
So that's, we're setting it up saying
we know where the file is,
but next we're gonna
add in some extra stuff,
which is arguably the most important thing
is the metadata for these
files that we're passing in.
So if you're doing this
in a bespoke manner,
you're gonna have to
do this for OpenSearch
differently for S3 Vector, different post,
whichever, you know,
name your vector store.
You're gonna have to figure
out how it's doing these
filtering mechanisms, and do
it for, or do it through those.
So like if you're using OpenSearch,
you're also on the query side,
you're gonna have to figure
out how do I do that query?
Or if it's pgVector, I have
to write the SQL query, right,
to do this with the filtering in place.
So I'm gonna add this in here
so we all know exactly
what I'm talking about.
So I'm adding in metadata, and again,
you could do this with S3 if
you want to do bulk ingestion.
There is the ability to put
metadata files in there.
But what this is allowing me
to do is to check those files
and individually pull them in.
And then also what I'm doing
here is setting the metadata,
the user ID, and
specifically the tenant ID,
so that when I'm doing the querying,
I can come back and do the
exact same thing in reverse,
I guess, is set the tenant and say,
"Hey, I want a query for that tenant."
There's one thing that I
am not showing in here is
I'm also adding these,
like I add them into the knowledge base
into the vector stores,
but I'm also adding a record
into a Dynamo database.
And in that database I'm setting
a time till I have a TTL,
which is, I think,
arguably one of the most
underrated things that
people just don't use
for some reason.
It's awesome, you can do
TTL or events and triggers
from other systems in AWS,
but the per record way of
doing it in Dynamo and it's,
I arguably say, very
cost-effective to do this.
That's what lets me set up
that expiry date in the files
that I showed in the demo, right?
There's a, you know, it's
an eight minute window,
or eight day window or
a day window, 24 hours,
whatever it is.
So I've now gone through the ingest,
I've set up the metadata
to be able to know
that I can filter on those.
And this metadata is in the vector stores,
tied to the vector stores.
This isn't in Dynamo,
a lot of this record-
- [Mike] Add some color to that.
I mean the key is that,
regardless of what vector
store you're using,
it's using this structure, right?
- [Steven] Yes.
- [Mike] That way you don't have to know
that it's a specific index in OpenSearch.
- [Steven] I don't have to duplicate this,
this code is like one set of code,
one set of queries that I
have to do across the board
for whatever vector stores
that the Bedrock knowledge base supports.
- [Mike] So to answer the
question that came up,
like why wouldn't you just talk directly
to the vector stores?
Well this gives you an abstraction layer
that allows you to work
at the metadata level
that would then push that
into the vector store,
regardless of, you know,
how that's being stored.
- All right, so now-
- We have a question
over here, I'm keeping an eye on time.
We're plenty good on time, so.
- [Steven] I feel like I
should be standing too,
but then I'm typing really odd and.
- [Audience Member] My
question would be like,
how would the system
react to nested metadata?
So for example, let's say we have a book,
a book has like multiple authors, so,
and authors would have like names.
And these names could be like,
in Japan you would have like names
in the Japanese characters.
- Yeah.
- In U.K. or U.S.
it'd be in English characters.
So how would you design your
metadata for Bedrock, or like,
you know, for more efficiently?
- [Steven] I'm not sure if that would,
so I think I understand
your question of like
Unicode characters or
other type of characters,
if they're in there or not.
In this form, I'm not sure
if that would really come into play,
because in this form
I'm saying a tenant ID,
and I'm filtering by a tenant and a user,
not specifically the content.
The content gets ingested as, you know,
whatever vector store is ingesting.
So it's using that embedding
model to break it apart.
So I think it would, the
question would be going back
to that embedding model
and making sure that it supports that.
So.
- In this case,
in this schema, can you have
a list be, or an object type
as part of the schema?
- [Steven] I'm not sure,
I'd have to figure,
go back and answer that.
- That's a research,
I think that's how I would
start looking for it.
But I don't have the answer
off the top of my head.
- [Steven] There's not
a definitive, there is,
in the querying side,
you can do and all kind of things, right?
So we're gonna get into that
a little bit in the next step.
Inserting the metadata
as an individual key,
as far as I'm aware, but I haven't.
- [Mike] I mean you certainly
could have author one,
author two, author three, but you'd be,
you'd have a finite list
of authors for your book.
So.
- [Steven] I'd have to,
yeah, if that's a question,
I'd have to get back to someone on
if the metadata supports array
fields and things like that.
Okay, so we've gone through,
we've set up our knowledge bases,
indexed files into the knowledge base.
So the next thing obviously is,
I want to ask it some questions.
So we want to go into the
querying of the knowledge base.
So what I'm going to do first is,
you'll see here we want
to set up a filter,
and I'm gonna zoom in 'cause we know,
just like everybody else, I can't see.
So in here we're gonna set
up a filter expression.
And this is where we're
going to be pulling in
the exact same stuff in the opposite.
So I'm gonna, for the
lack of being able to type
really quickly on the fly.
Oh, wrong, wrong one.
Let's copy the right set of stuff, Steve.
That definitely helps.
One sec.
All right, so when we're
doing a query, so up above we,
this is another Lambda
call that is coming in.
We, from the chat session, right,
it called in through the JWT token.
I would be able to get
my tenant ID, my user ID,
other information like that.
So I've pulled it out
up above in this code.
And the key thing to look at here though
is this filter expression.
And what it's doing is
it's setting up that tenant
and the user id, and
then I'm also passing in
a list of files.
So this could actually be
a little bit useful as well
later on is, even if they're
indexed, you could say,
I actually only want to query
on three of the hundred files
that are in there,
because, to Mike's point,
sometimes wikis go out of date
or other files go out of date.
And if the time hasn't expired,
but I know I'm really
focused on my search,
I could query on that.
In this particular example, I
just pass in all my file IDs
that have been indexed, so
that I'm searching for my files
and I'm filtering layer after layer
to make sure that I'm
getting just the stuff
that I want to query on.
- [Mike] And it's leaving
nothing to chance.
So if someone should inject
in the prompt, you know,
send me all of the data about tenant two,
that's not going to
really help them at all.
- [Steven] Yeah.
So then we have to set up
our retrieval parameters.
So again, I'm not going to
type everything in here, 'cause time.
So the retrieval parameters
are setting up the query
and then we're setting up a, you know,
the model we're gonna
use for turning our query
into the embedding, for the model.
And then we're passing in right
here, our filter expression.
And then we can control the
number of results as well.
So once we do that,
now we can go into the
retrieve and generate section.
I'm gonna zoom back out
here and go to my dodos,
make sure I got that stuff.
Okay.
So I think highlighted out some code,
I'm just gonna put that
back in there, so it's,
the three programs are good, okay.
- [Mike] And zoom in on that section.
- [Steven] Yeah, I'm
gonna just leave it as
highlighted out code.
So what we've done here is
we've set up our parameters.
Once we've set that up,
we would be calling a perform,
retrieve and generate call.
So inside of the knowledge base querying,
I'm gonna find that, while,
hey, where it'd go, sorry.
I'm bouncing around because I,
so from the Bedrock agent runtime,
we're gonna call the
retrieve and generate,
and we're passing in
those retrieval results.
So this is where, again,
back to the point of like
why would you use Bedrock knowledge bases?
I set that up as a query
for Bedrock knowledge bases.
I didn't have to really
understand what's going on
underneath the hood, what
vector store that I'm going to.
I'm doing this, I could do this across
every single vector store that
Bedrock knowledge bases has,
and I don't have to
change this model at all.
So if you wanted to have,
like if another customer
came to you and said,
"Hey, I've got a bespoke use case
where I want to use a different
type of vector store."
Maybe there's government
regulatory, whatever it is,
you don't have to worry about it.
You can just spin that up as
part of your infrastructure
and then just point the code to it,
and you should be good to go.
- [Mike] So it gives you a nice
clean separation of concerns.
- Yeah.
- [Mike] Vector store with the query.
As far as the chunking,
where's the chunking happening,
and where do you configure that?
- [Steven] It's part of the
knowledge base configuration.
So when we're setting
up the knowledge base,
we're setting up the data
source and we're gonna set up
some of the chunking
strategies inside of there.
But also when we go back to the indexing,
we've set up some of it in here.
- [Mike] I sprung that on him, so.
- [Steven] When we're
setting it up though,
we're setting up individual data sources
and data vector source as a
specific chunking strategy
and things like that.
And then in the query side,
we are doing the same
thing with the query.
So you're setting up the
model that you're gonna use,
the foundational model,
and some of the options
that you have there.
It's not really the chunking there,
you're just basically picking the model
to be able to do the embeddings, but.
- [Mike] Any other questions?
There we go.
- [Steven] After the question
we go on to the last little
bit, is just the cleanup part.
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
Maybe it does it automatically
but, if tenant two,
for example, is chatting with
their own index of documents
and whatsoever, and I update
one of those documents,
but how does the tenant know
that the document is updated
and the embedding is regenerated again,
but I don't want to lose the
context of the chat basically.
So the document is updated,
the embedding should be
regenerated, but the context
be lost, right.
- Yeah, you,
if I get your question right is like,
if I'm continuing on a
chat and I wanna search
more and more things,
you just have to keep passing the context
in of the previous stuff.
- Yeah.
- So you do start getting
a longer and longer context
window that happens there.
And I don't have a good answer for you
on seeing if we can slim that down at all.
I think you'll see like even in Kiro,
and some of the newer systems
out there, they start,
they'll hit a limit and then
they'll summarize for you
and try to push that
off to something else.
So those are kind of the patterns
that have come into play these days.
Until someone smarter than I comes up with
a better pattern for that.
- Okay, thanks.
- Other questions?
- [Steven] All right.
The last little bit of
this is just the cleanup.
So we've gone through again
the stages, we've ingested,
we've queried.
Now, as we mentioned, we've
got a TTL system, right?
So whenever the TTL triggers,
we've gotta go back and make sure,
because we're a custom store,
there's nothing going on
that specifically tells us
to clean up all that information.
So we've actually gotta go in
and extract out the file information
and everything like that
from the TTL trigger.
So in the Dynamo database
basically there's a
couple of things in there.
It's the file ID, the
data source that it's in,
the knowledge base that it's in
and we're gonna use that information
and we're going to extract it out
and delete those records
from the knowledge base.
And again, in this particular spot
we don't really have to care
what knowledge base it is,
we're just giving it a command
and it figures out what that needs to be
and goes off and deletes it.
So I am going to grab
that chunk of code here,
and it's a rather large chunk of code
so I'm not gonna type it in here.
Sorry, one second.
- [Mike] While you're doing that, I mean,
when Steven showed this to me,
I thought this was one
of the more clever parts
of the solution because,
the time to live is a
really important problem
and you can't just have a single rule
for all of your documents.
Like how do you manage that?
So, you know, keeping a
record of that index in Dynamo
and then using the Dynamo DB stream
to essentially trigger that action,
gives you a lot of flexibility,
'cause you can use the built-in
time to live within Dynamo
or you could delete the record manually
if there's like a right to forget,
or if you're trying to expire
a document, like you said,
you just delete the record in Dynamo
and it will just flow
through the whole system.
- [Steven] Yeah, so I
was a little off there.
It's not a super large chunk of code.
But this is definitely, as I mentioned,
all I have to keep track
of in the Dynamo database
is the knowledge base it's coming from,
the data source it's coming from,
and the file ID that I wanna remove.
Technically I could probably
put some extra parameters
in here if I want to be
very bespoke about like
the tenant ID and things like that,
and make sure we're going through.
But for deleting from a knowledge base
really just needs the file ID,
from wherever the data source was.
So I'm passing in that file
ID and then it's going off
and deleting it out of
whatever knowledge base.
So it handles the create and
the query and things like that.
That said, it's just deleting
out of the vector store,
it's not deleting out of
the storage underlying.
So these are separated off systems
that we're dealing with too.
So I've still got files
sitting there in S3
that I could re-ingest
later if I really needed to.
But I'm just not taking out all the use
of those particular
knowledge stores, or sorry,
vector stores as well.
So that kind of ties it up
where we've gone through all the stages,
we cleaned up the data,
and now the users are hopefully happy
because they've got a better
utilization of their system.
Hopefully their costs are
going down a little bit.
But I would love to
hear from everybody too,
like what vector stores
is everybody else using,
or did we kind of peg it with
the Postgres, OpenSearch?
Has anybody started using S3 Vector yet?
So one person.
- Couple here.
- [Steven] Has anybody
found it useful and good
compared to others?
Yeah?
Okay.
I think the, when the cloud formation
kind of catches up on that,
we're hoping that people
will start really kicking in
and using those things.
- [Mike] Any other vector
stores that you're using?
- [Audience Member] Well
I had more of a question,
basically.
- Yeah, go.
- [Audience Member] We use
OpenSearch Serverless and
one of the major issues
that we are basically having
is that in the listing of the documents
within the data source, if
we use open server list,
what's happening is
that the API that we use
from internal services
to query the database,
that kind of times out if you have like
even greater than like 10
documents or something.
So is there like a workaround we can use
to kind of pre-filter the
knowledge base so that, you know,
we retrieve results in, you know,
less than 10 seconds or so?
- [Mike] You can hold on to that.
I have some follow-up questions for you.
What type of metadata do
you have on the documents?
- [Audience Member] So it's
basically like file ID mainly,
and then, you know, we
have the agent ID in there
to kind of know,
like this is the file
that we need to query.
- Yep.
- Get the results
and that works perfectly.
The major issue that we are having is like
when we have the user
interface for the customer
to see the file that they've ingested
into the knowledge space,
that's where it times out.
Because the pagination is like,
it happens very weirdly,
like it's super slow.
So is there like a
workaround that we can use
to when we are, you know,
listing the knowledge base documents,
is there like a metadata that we can pass
to kind of pre-filter the
documents, so that's maybe faster?
- [Steven] Yeah so, it
sounds a little bit more like
OpenSearch specific type of question.
- Exactly, yeah.
- I would love to get you
set with an OpenSearch specialist,
if you haven't talked to one so far.
- But see, in your demo-
- It sounds like though,
I mean if you went behind
like a Bedrock knowledge base
and you used something like this,
then you could maybe get the
users to try to track down,
or have like different
sets of files that are,
or documents that they're looking at.
I think one thing that we've noticed is,
knowledge bases can get really big,
and the stuff that individual
people wanna look at
is like maybe 10% of the overall.
So you could segment it
down to by department,
or by something like that, right?
So putting in some of that metadata
so you could filter it down that way
before you start to do
the retrieve and generate,
might help you out on that.
- [Audience Member] So
a follow up on that.
So let's say since it's
a multi-gen system,
and I think there's like
an upper limit or quota
for like the number of
knowledge bases that we can have
in a single account versus
the number of data sources.
So how we kind of tackle that, I guess.
So we run into a bottleneck eventually
in terms of scaling, right?
That's the main issue, I guess.
- [Mike] And it, how Steven
addressed that in his demo is,
he kept that record of files in Dynamo.
- Right?
- So if you're just
listing the files, it's
not actually hitting
the knowledge base or OpenSearch.
- Right.
- Just hitting
Dynamo instead.
And then the tenant ID,
you don't have a
knowledge base for tenant,
you do the segmentation
using the metadata on the-
- [Audience Member] Yeah so
maybe like, I think, I guess,
moving to a Dynamo DB base
like file information,
or something that could help us, I guess.
- [Steven] Yeah if you're just tracking
peer file information stuff,
I would say OpenSearch is maybe not,
like OpenSearch is really good
at what it does, but it's,
if you're just querying
out flat based information,
Dynamo's probably gonna
be a good spot to put in,
and it'll alleviate some of the load
on your OpenSearch as well,
so you don't have to like
increase the size of your cluster at all.
- [Audience Member] All
right, thank you so much.
- [Mike] Good question.
I'll be right over.
- [Audience Member] So in
term of Vector DB, a year ago,
before starting using KB,
we were using MongoDB Atlas.
Find out that the LM wasn't
very good to do a text
to a Mongo query, so we have a few issues.
And so since now we are using OpenSearch
and not Alphabet Postgre.
But we still have a footprint
on Mongo and so I'm,
but we're doing like normal
rack without KB anything.
So I'm wondering if we
could use KB with Mongo
at some point.
- [Steven] I, we just checked this too,
I don't know if Mongo is on the list.
I'd have to get back to you.
I'm not sure if Mongo's on the
Bedrock knowledge base list
of Vector store or support.
But if it was, then it would
be, yes, you could do that.
And it would just generate
the queries and everything for you.
- [Mike] I told 'em they'd stump us.
- [Steven] Yeah, I know.
And it's funny, I was just
looking over these things,
like I know someone's
gonna ask about that.
- [Audience Member] We've
been interested in using
Neptune Analytics just for
general like knowledge graph,
but also some, a little
bit of vector storage,
'cause I think there's that feature
within Neptune Analytics.
How have you found the integration
between knowledge bases
with other vector stores?
Like is there a little more customization
that needs to be done for Neptune?
- [Steven] I haven't seen too many.
Like I know, like Neptune
Vectors is, or is,
I wouldn't say new.
It's been around for a little bit.
- Newish, yeah.
- But, yeah, newish.
So I haven't personally come across
too many that are mixing
those together, so.
But I mean, when you're
setting up the data sources
to the knowledge base through Bedrock,
it's pretty much the
same configuration stuff
that you would do for like
whatever vector store
that you're gonna go to.
You have a lot of the knobs and dials
that you're gonna tweak.
So I would say, if you're
tweaking through without it,
then you're probably gonna
be doing the same thing
through the knowledge base.
You're just saving the switching
between the knowledge bases
and having to rewrite
queries and things like that.
It'd be interesting question
to the knowledge base team
to see how they're doing the
performance enhancing, right?
'Cause they're gonna be
doing the queries for you
into the knowledge store.
So it'd be very interesting to see like
if you're finding that you're
having performance issues
or anything like that.
I'd love to get like
that team in front of it
and see how they are doing those queries
and like what data
specifically you're using.
So maybe bump into me after
this and we can figure that out.
- [Mike] Any others?
- [Steven] All good, yeah?
- [Mike] I think if there
are no more questions,
we've solved everything.
We've solved every problem,
so that's good to hear.
Really appreciate you taking the time.
Make sure to put the feedback in the app
and I think we're
probably between everyone
and lunch as well,
so letting out a couple of minutes early
is not the end of the world.
So thanks everyone for attending.